some naked ladies and a man yes man can
sit down ladies were on already yeah was
that tough for you to do a scene with
people that are naked I just I don't
look anywhere but up here I can't tell
you what they look like you would only
look at their eyes only their eyes yeah
yeah - terrified - I can't and I'm
terrified also just embarrassing to be
anyone to see me going like that I'm
like I'm very unprofessional I make wolf
nor I Bacall and my eyes can actually go
out and back in that's what the guy
that's what the guy forget the girl
it causes all kinds of trouble in the
men's room that's what I always do at
the urinal
[Applause]
take a binocular holy moley
that's why I get asked to leave a lot of
all right well let's get back enough
about my life now I have to start doing
that I think if I did it for real people
the guy wouldn't think it was that funny
I know that's the problem miss Annie now
talk but when I really do it I'm gonna
get that [ __ ] kick not anymore
times have changed you're right
you